the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok a recap of last lecture we start to
talk about liquids I said I couldn't
deal with the nuclear the using the
approach that we have been using for
dilute particles towards my face the
equation for example and so the
discussion on liquid is incomplete and
very short we started on bulk liquid we
said a very useful definition is a
measure is the radio distribution
function which actually measure the
structure of the liquid itself and then
we introduced the one-word equation of
states historically it's very important
and of course we know the ideal gas
equation but the one word equation of
states actually give you the liquid and
solid states and know the vapor and
liquid states and also give you the
transition between the liquid to vapor
so we Purdum at least qualitatively and
then say in terms of treating the
transport and liquid their approach in
the past modifying they boards my
equation and this UN Cherie was they say
it's a for example consider rather than
boards my equation is a single particle
distribution function two particle
distribution function that was the on
scope approach free and but as I
mentioned was not very successful
because it can really deal with the
Newman with a very complete unscored
equation which I didn't write down how
you cannot deal with over a liquid you
can
do is approximate treating the denser
gas but it can be extended to liquid so
they then we talked about the einstein's
approach his proposed objective was
actually determine the size of molecules
small particles and he can save the
Brownian motion picture although there
were experiments Brown ended experiment
long before I start but he didn't seem
to realize and so loud hood his work was
a key dunking as he is good at and he
showed the relation between the
diffusivity and the viscosity
diffusivity of particles in the fluid
and the viscosity of the fluid and
that's an example of the fluctuation
which is diffusion and dissipation which
is viscosity
it's example of a fluctuation
dissipation theorem and from the I stand
approach there was an extension to
Langevin equation of motion so it is
essentially F equals MA except in the
fourth term there are two terms one is a
random driving force and the other is a
drag force so when you have particle in
a fluid moving we know that picture is
the stalks drag but that's actually very
general its basic breakfast is
proportional to velocity and I comment
the even the LNG vanquishing I was not a
quite the way that's written because it
didn't consider this time the finite
time response when you use the stock
solution if you actually write down the
time response of the stocks equals a
solution you actually get an integral
differential equation
so you've seen integral equation quite a
few times
so that's a they will come back to
continue some of this discussion in the
last lecture but then we turn our
attention to deal with surfaces and say
interface in liquids and we started with
potentials and the forces so where
what's the most important in fact I
think somewhere I said before if you
understand energy you understand
momentum you understand the second
entropy you understand at least to say
or the mechanical world right and the F
equals C the force itself is the
gradient of the potential so we start
discussing the force particularly we
focused on the columbic force the force
interaction due to the charge we cannot
easily deal with the covalent force
right where you have to really solve the
Schrodinger equation but for the force
interaction due to the charge direct non
red charge interaction Coulomb big force
you can write starting with the point
potential construct with what if you
have two positive negative charge
together there's a dipole and then you
have one point charged to a dipole
and you have dipole-dipole and you can
do dipole to similar infinite object and
finally we give expression for example
what's the force the one wores force
detained
that's the dipole dipole based model
dipole interaction between two Simon
infinite plates and the potential is
inversely proportional to the separation
D the ten is two surfaces and this
potential is a you can see when you go
to
smaller D it goes to more negative so
it's attractive potential and so
attractive force between the two
surfaces and on the top the constant
here is also called Hamaker constant and
it has it's a physical region if you
learn C D if you do phase change your
property series Hamaker constant before
and with that's the Casimir force its
dipole-dipole of this dipole the one
watch force is dipole-dipole interaction
and the extension of that is the Casimir
force and the Casimir force is a as I
explained it was a idea that the force
between the two object one and the two
and can be think about the energy stored
in this space between one to the medium
that's right
it could be vacuum and when I think
about energy stored and there is a zero
point we learned at the quantization 1/2
1/2 H nu and then how many modes you
have the electromagnetic wave modes in
this space and if you each mode
container energy 1/2 H nu you do that
summation of the total energy and you
find out that I CD to surface gets
closer to closer each other you're
excluding modes so the energy is
decreasing so you have attractive force
so that give the quantum spin to the one
worse they force interaction picture and
that was the Casimir very simple paper
interest you can read it and then there
was the extension by Liv she's the non
delicious book delicious is solving this
problem from electromagnet L AM
explained you basically solve they
consider the force interaction as I say
due to the zero point
so 0.0 means what there's no temperature
they are right so any object is
uncertain so the position is not fixed
so zero point has a fluctuation and this
fluctuating or generally electromagnetic
wave the electromagnetic wave propagate
to this side and that will create an
interaction between the two sides so you
basically saw a Maxwell equation and
then that jiggling is again connected to
the so called the fluctuation
dissipation theorem so you can calculate
the force interaction from
electrodynamics perspective and that's a
much more general theory so what you
have is one two three and what you need
is the dielectric constant if some one
which could be a function of frequency
and you've seen onto which could be a
function of frequency Epsons 3 which
could be a function of frequency so with
that you can calculate the force
interaction in any medium sometimes the
two the medium in between are not vacuum
it could be another material right and
in fact that there is a myself we even
have a little confusion here this
concept again if you do phase change
you'll probably encounter how many of
you have heard this John in pressure
anybody had heard about that okay yeah
this joining pressure is again a lot of
concept that encounter in the phase
change process for example if you
consider the evaporation of a liquid
film right so you have a corner and then
equate the film was spread and of course
there is a surface tension part right
but there could be another part say very
very thin film spreading much larger
distance and people say that's because
of this janym janym pressure and they
are reason for that is you can think
about this as a medium
one vacuum is a media remember or see
any space and for the electromagnetic
wave is a medium and that the liquid
film is medium three and whatever the
solid is a medium to write so I can
calculate the three medium would then
say what's the interaction and then
turns out the in some of test right most
of the case
this is attractive in some cases they're
the forcing between could will also be
repulsive okay if it's a repulsive force
then there actually will be a stable
layer of liquid that's sustained on the
surface and that so that if it's the
evaporation if it's a heating then if
you have a liquid film you help your
heat transfer right so there is this
disjoining pressure that people
sometimes use I think if anyway is the
interesting the understand is you should
look more into the literature okay so
this is a the picture that we have in
terms of an attractive force where we're
going is talking about as I mentioned
before is I have a suspension particles
in the liquid and the widest suspension
I can sometimes make this stable why
sometimes I can make this table right
and of course if we is all attractive
one words force then I will not have
stability because the part of our you
interleague glue to each other and
sediment because of gravity right so
what I leave is a repulsive force and in
the well say common repulsive force
particular rating ionic solution like
say water is the electrical double layer
so let's spend the Louboutin discuss
electric double layer
so a lot of solid surfaces when you
immersing in solution the solid itself
the surface contains charge right and
you can think about for example if I
have a oxygen tribulation on the surface
if I put in water right what could be
happening as you think this will be a
hydrophilic hydrophobic surface that the
like water doesn't make void
it will be hydrophilic most likely right
because most likely the surface has
oxygen oxygen is a negative charge and
water has a hydrogen and the hydrogen
and the oxygen or bound to each other
right and so lot of surface actually
have a lead surface charge either
because of the asymmetry of the bounds
because on the surface atom is different
from internal you don't have the
surrounding atom to balance it oh it's
just because it just absorb some ions
onto it to have a ligand here so let
charge on the surface so you have on the
solid surface typically right ah let's
say here I'm drawing the just inside I
got a a net balance of a charge on the
surface negative charge and now if I
emerged in a solution that has a
positive negative ions and you know that
the positive ions will go towards the
surface just to balance it right so what
happens is some of this ion will be
pretty much glued because the bond is
strong enough so the first molar layer
or pretty much in like glued on the
surface and once you are I see one
monitor way that force interaction
decays rapidly and the bonding will not
be strong enough to hold it so this
other counter ions will move around the
surface but say because of the charge
imbalance so there will be a let a more
charge right mobile ads in this region
in the liquid so what we will create is
in the surface region like a capacitor
on the say solid side you have one type
of volt charge ions and on the liquid
side you got another type
Lyle's right this forms a electrical
double layer and in fact if you define
more carefully and the eMobile layer
alpha ions is a stin there
it's called stern okay and then the
mobile layer between this Stern layer
and outside where eventually they will
go the charge will go to neutrality the
bulk origin of the fluids words not
influenced by the surface right so this
layer is the double area if you do
electrochemical devices if you do super
capacitors for example where super
capacitor is capacitance is a
proportional if you think about
capacitors capacitance is a proportional
to area right and it is universally
proportional to distance and the
dielectric constant right so super
capacitor is a one that you create a
large surface area by making non-porous
materials and then you put in the
electrolyte because how you can create a
capacitance near you create the
electrolyte and put it into there and
you hope that the capacitors and local
capacitance between the electrolyte and
solid and using that to form your total
capacitance of a super capacitor right
and in super capacitor this layer is
very important not just to the electric
double layer and if you do electro
kinetics right if you in actual kinetics
including natural osmosis and and where
the particle moves or when you apply
electric
field or say the liquid mode in the
United kinetics is the wing so both are
because either the particles charge the
solids charge they were all the other
case is a liquid discharge right so this
is we now in those cases the electric
double layer very important and so first
the density of the I on the surface so
density of iron surface and this one can
be related to the case when you have
zero are charged on the surface right so
one case that you don't have any charge
on the surface what's the density so
this is the zero point charge density
and then we have because I have certain
ions adsorbed on the surface right I
have then say a surface potential and
divided by Kb T so this is essentially
the board's my statistics portsmen
distribution right if you recall the
boards and distribution what we have is
the energy over KBT right the
probability of certain particles having
certain energy and this energy is
related to energy is related who you
like to a static potential plus I by the
charge Q right normalized to charge and
the Q is if I have a atom that has a
certain number alpha for example protons
Z right and then Z times the e gives me
the charge E is the charge per electron
so q is Z that's why I have the e times
your actual static potential which is
surface potential divided by KBT okay
and this gives me a way to actually
define the surface potential at the log
and you can universe there now what I
would like to find is what's the
potential electrostatic potential
distribution in the double layer okay so
because I have a surface potential to
sign from the surface on the surface
right and then when I move away from the
surface there will be a distribution
because that potential you actually
would disappear and I want to say how
thick is this layer is the electrical
double layer so from the solving the
distribution so the way I do it is they
look into the Poisson equation which is
a one of the four Maxwell equations
right so what we had in the Maxwell
equation is the displacement divergence
equals the led charge per unit volume at
local charge density that's what we we
had before and D will be let me write a
1d form I don't have to do too
complicated
so I will write epsilon right or if so
non 0 epsilon R this is the day you
sonars relative dielectric constant
epsilon 0 is dielectric constant vacuum
together give me the EEPROM and so this
will be x day electric field right
because d equals e from x e e you'll
actually feel and so electric field i
use usually write a large or epsilon I'm
running out of symbols and DX equals 0
right and electrical field is a the
gradient of the electrostatic potential
negative greedy right so I have really
epsilon epsilon R the negative gradient
of the electrostatic potential DX square
so that's on the left hand side of the
Poisson equation right on the right hand
side I need to write my charge so recall
here is my solid and locally I have a
electrostatic potential right and give
an electrostatic potential I know the
energy is a Q I say in fact this is
reverse sorry this is the pass I equals
to the energy times Q right so energy
local energy is the electrostatic energy
is a Q times plus i right and then no
core bozeman statistical distribution
for that specie can be written as they
let's say is I have a Zi different
species in the solution zi e so this is
the force pci and per ion and the
density of the aisle 0 means
semi-infinite way and now because
locally i have a potential difference
from the you semi-infinite so I have zi
e poss-eye
that's the energy divided by Kb T so
this is the board's my distribution
boards my distribution how many
particles each particle card is much
charged and I sum up with all the
species in the I right and here I got a
so called our persone Boltzmann equation
okay here we have a soon I don't want to
write the poison how to write for soon -
to SPO okay so boards man right so
solving this platoon boards my equation
you should be able to obtain the lokor
field you like to start your field
distribution in the double layer and
then turns out this is a not so easy to
solve the in factor you could solve this
problem or reversely
and the first one was approximately
solution and this first approximation
was by the by it's called the type of
Debye Huckle solution theory okay
bye-bye
taco theory and it's Nene ERISA so
rather than using the exponential we
will assume that exponential can be
linearized and this happens when the
exponent is small so when the potential
is not a large zi e si much less than
KBT and remember KBT is of the order KBT
is 26 and milli electron volts at room
temperature so this in fact that is a
poor approximation and in most cases the
surface potential will be larger in many
qualities that I know is larger than
this value so it's not a very good one
but it gives it very instructive because
so because of this I can actually
linearize it so if someone are
on the side the x squared and the equals
I so zi e ends of your eye and in your
eyes so I get one mass zi e side and KBT
right and infinite away away from the
double-layer I have balance of ligand
here and positive charge so that's
neutrality so I have positive and
negative this of the first term is
actually zero right so what I have then
on the left hand side if the first term
is zero I can plot the plus I I have i
zi square e square and the KBT and n0i
so now I actually get a simple second
order differential equation for the
potential distribution near the surface
here right it's exponential decay
function as you can see the second-order
this is a your constant if I divide the
epsilon0 epsilonr to this side this is a
constant for that exponential decay so
what I have then the potential and what
I really want to say this potential I
should use because I'm dealing with the
double layer
I should not actually use plus is I
should use the potential potential at
this point this is the s 0 that's where
I start looking into the decay the
diffuse layer here so what I have here
is poss-eye
s0 exponential mass X over Delta and
this Delta the inverse of this data is
just the square root of what I've
written here so the square root
of i zi square e i a square and n0 i and
epsilon 0 if some are KB T so this Delta
is self Delta is quoted the violence and
you go to look at the literature in
semiconductor PN Junction the space
charge region is the same expression in
fact when you solve for the potential of
a appearan Junction you solve the same
for some Boltzmann equation and you use
this linearization you get a similar
expression and that is also called the
by length in PN Junction and the history
is the electrochemical battery cos was a
long developed between the PN Junction
right so you can see the solid-state
devices actually use this concept that
was developed for the electrochemical in
electrochemistry okay so it will be
interesting to see what does this mean
how thick is this Debye length right if
I have water I put some salt into it
what's my dependence I should be able to
estimate given the expression here let's
take my example I'm going to put a one
grain of salt sodium chloride and into
water input in one neither water one
kyogen either 1 meter of water right and
what I need to find out that what's the
solution in a way what's the equilibrium
concentration of the ions you see
concentration of the ions
and just dielectric constants a
dielectric constant right and this is a
humorous so one could be leader say
millimeter and the density alpha south
is 2.5 so the density is 2 point 5 gram
per cubic centimeter so with this I will
get what I have here is 10 to the minus
3
so here is a 10 to macerate cubic
centimeter times 2 point 5 gram per
centimeter and I have here what I have
here this is a centimeters no this is
centimeter and I have 2.5 mini gram
right of salt and then how much is that
in terms of more so I realize my notes
that has a 10 to the minus 3 order
magnitude difference I forgot this so
say the in terms of more is 2.5 10 to
the minus 3 gram right and the molar
mass of sodium chloride sodium is 11
colorized 17 so total is 28 times the
motorbike factor of 2
that's my molar mass so so here I have
is 56 gram per mole and this will give
me point zero four five ten to the minus
three more now okay so this is a this is
my mole number and then I also know why
more I have
Avogadro's constant so I have how many
ions inside right so what I have here I
multiplied Avogadro constant egg a which
is this six 10 to the mass a positive
twenty-three irons per mole so I have
this number of ions 23 so I will get
this equals thick okay so the Lambert
density is a per liter right so point
zero four five ten to the minus three
and six to ten to twenty three that's
the number of ions per liter is a 10 to
the minus 3 meter cubic meter and so
this cancel and what I have is 0.27 10
to the 23 per cubic meter
that's the Caleb Riley right so if you
go to do this I think I my length here
because this one what I have Delta
because the dielectric constant water is
about eighty right water is a very large
dielectric constant if you go to a polar
liquid right then the dielectric
constant will be much smaller and the
because of that is actually much harder
to put ion into a polar liquid so it's
the water you can dissolve our much
easier because a large dielectric
constant but anyway so if you do that
what I have here or region at 1.5 but I
here because I realized I miss this so
it should be 10 to the third nanometer
you can go to check so this will give me
15 to 20 nanometer tens of nanometer yes
proceed you use the full nuclear charge
of the screen nuclear charge ah I
usually know I use the adjusted e the
balance here I said I should use the
screened I use screen wait a second so
what should I use Z if I think about it
z yeah it's a it's a issue use screen
it's it's a lab let's charge you have
most of the iron are the electrons is
glue down to the nuclear I should use
the charge of the mobile let's charge of
the mobile ions okay so the point is you
can say the typical Debye length is of
the order depends on how much how much
Saudi put there of order of tens
nanometers right you put it more south
your the balance will be smaller and you
put the lists out the balance will be
longer so this is the influence of the
electric double layer how far away the
extent in the liquid and now once I have
that then the next question is this is
around a single surface and what's the
pressure right and what's the force
between two surfaces so to understand
that I can think about first if I have a
double layer with this you can also use
this as the effective width thickness
the full capacitor right the capacitor
is a positively charged and that's your
effective thickness and the good thing
is with capacitor this difference to
turn electric double layer and PN
Junction is that there really is no
charge ions cannot get into the solid
right pin Junction you have electrons
you have
they can run combine so you sell them
user pin judge simple pin joint in the
store charge but you can use the
electrical double layer to store charge
for better for the super capacitors
right because and once the ions getting
into the solid you become a say a
chemical reaction that's your battery
they're your battery actually is the ion
gets into into the electrode right so
what we have here let's look at the
pressure so I have for example I have
negative I on the surface I have counter
and positive and they will attract to
each other right so I have a tractive
force and if I have force unless I have
counter force otherwise all the Sun
should go to the plate right it will
move so I got got to have a counter
force the counter force is the pressure
I have generated in the double layer so
I have a pressure I can think this is
the P this is P X plus DX and this is a
DX right so the balance of this pressure
force is against the electrostatic force
so I write the force balance and the
force balance it will tell me this is a
DP DX and negative and plus the density
of the charge times the electric field
on the charge is d PSI DX and this
should balance it right so this is the
force balance and of course now I have
the solution for the in fact that you
can use the original integral plus sign
boards might say put some force my
equation you can write this as deep C
equals minus D per side because you can
integrate DX directly get rid of it and
the charge density
i zi e n0i exponential minus epsilon not
zi e zi e plus I and K V T so in this
case I do not this is just a charge
density I'm reading in the right hand
side I'll put some boys around equation
I can integrate without any
approximation in this case and if you do
it integration I get a P at the X minus
the P I the infinite I integrate to
infinite an infinite way this is the
concentrations and 0 I so I will have
Sigma I and KBT and I X minus and 0 I so
if you look at this and you can think
this size this related here so I have
positive ions here trapped and I have
more positive answer than infinite way
so this term is a positive so what it
means is the pressure is a positive is
higher in the double layered and higher
than the pressure away from the EE ok
and now when I have two surfaces because
I want to look at right I have direct
the force interaction that's one word
for Casimir force in the ration between
the two surfaces that's what it
discussed before and now because the
pressure in the double layer is a
positive so when I bring the two
surfaces very close the pressure is a
positive inside you will repulse the two
surface so I have a repulsion force that
could balance the attraction force right
so this is the repulsive force due to
the electric double layer now with that
I can now start thinking about when I
put a liquid particles into liquid when
they are stable
because I have attractive when the words
force and I have also a repulsive
electrostatic the double air force here
so I have in terms of the separation of
the two particles right illa liquid when
they are getting closer closer
that's one worse force right and when
they are getting closer together the
pressure in between the liquid due to
the electric double layer increases and
that's a repulsive so this is the
potential from the force to potential
and the superimposed a tool and you see
which one wins and if the one device
force is very strong you will be just
attract to each other and so what do you
want so if I do the superposition of the
two forces you could have different
scenarios and the one scenario is like
this right and here is the one verse
force and then the repulsive potential
due to the electrostatic when they get
in really close this one dorsal force
once again so it started to attract to
each other and now if you look at that
are the situation the particle tends to
stay to minimum right minimum energy
point and there are a different scenario
one minimum is here and the absolute
minimum is here right and this minimum
if the potential barrier here is much
larger than the KT then you actually
have a quasi stable colloid is a quasi
stable
right you can stay this way keep a
distance between the particles and until
somehow you force them much closer right
so this is the difference in area you
can have that will push the particle
away and all you could have this the one
words just four wins right and in this
case you'll ever get a stability I
wasn't sure whether you in this case you
can get stability because this I'm going
to consider only two bottlers maybe all
push to the boundaries of the container
right and so this one is the real say
cause I see metastable state and that's
when you make you want to use the
electrostatic of messer to stabilize the
colloids and in that case you know right
if you want to destabilize it you add a
drop of salt you were just a fall to the
bottom you change your electrostatic
potential and there are different ways
there are other ways so this is when you
deal with the ionic solution you do it's
much easier and when you do it with a
non-polar solution where you cannot just
the ions concentration in the solution
it's much more difficult and in that
case what you do is you for example
rapid a surface of the particle with
polymers and then you use the
configuration or repulsion and see
people call different their their
different way different forces in this
case to stabilize the solution so use
insert this is a surfactant way to
stabilize and in fact I was thinking
even this morning
whether the surfactant how to I haven't
checked I have to say I haven't check
the literature people use a entropic
energy or that to explain I was just
thinking whether one
could still go to modify the NIF she's
not significant theory and somehow
whether this polymer can introduce
repulsion just like we say you have you
can have a repulsive force if the
dielectric constant of the medium is
that different but I wasn't sure I
didn't acknowledge I didn't check
literature okay
so that's the basics with the electric
double layer and if you do micro
fluidics or nano philippics you know
that people have used the electric
double layer when you deal with the
liquid this is where a lot of technology
advances in the past and people using
the electric double layer to do to make
devices and one of this well stabs you
is this is long before micro
nanotechnology okay that's the electro
osmosis right and all your actual for
edits first electro phoretic and if the
for attica is always some particles
moving solids the movie and when we have
electro phoretic what i mean is i have
particles i put in your liquid Alec I
say ionic liquid and the particle will
of course have absorbed the ions right
and then say the surrounding has a
counter ions and the effectively going
to apply a electric field on the
particle they will move depends on the
let imbalance right so you factory with
this partner is like charged particle
and I'll give an electrical field the
particular mode right and of course the
motion is a balance cell for the driving
force which is the electro static force
the charge times the electric field
balance of the drag force
which is a typical small particle you
can use this stocks expression right so
if I do this apply electric field and in
fact that you can say depends on whether
it's a positive or negative charge you
can go different directions right
surface charge so use that you can tell
whether your surface of the solid is
charged positive or negatively and even
though say their surrounding charge
you're moving with it in liquid but
there's a lab charge difference right so
I have that say I do the balance is 3 PI
mule D times of velocity that's the
storks force and then I have the D
charge on the surface Q times the
electric field and this gives me the
velocity I can easily kill times
electrical field apply and 3 PI mu D
right you use this tool for example you
can measure the velocity of the part of
you're moving you can use that to do
your part of your sizing or you can also
use that so say most of time people
actually use this to determine the Q on
the surface right and the Q is this one
is not the surface potential because
it's a lat surface right because it has
if I the particle is negatively charged
they're surrounding also positive
charges that are here to the surface and
there are some shear there's some mobile
charges still moving with it so
effectively you are really is looking at
that they let charged in a certain
sphere that effective movement with the
solid right and this potential you can
go to say what's the effective potential
that's your zeta potential
that's zeta potential is this q + 2 pi
epsilon 0 epsilon R and approximately is
the thickness of the double layer and
the D is diameter over 2 so when this is
a much larger than the diameter you can
see that the measure and see that
potential is effective you know it's
measuring the number of charge okay so
this is the electro phoretic flow where
you use the field to drive the particle
motion and people have you have you can
actually buy commercial equipment that's
the for example they measured is either
potential pretty much based on this
principle and the other situation is
let's suppose I you want to use the
electric field to drive a fluid flow in
the channel right and if you have solid
you have a liquid inside and you have in
this case if you apply a voltage
electric field in the flow in the actual
direction and now what happens is of
course you have fixed the ions that do
not move you have then tabular ions
that's mobile and this double layer of
course is only near the surface right so
if we apply a electric field this
Doppler will move the supposedly in the
these are the positive charged double
layer and they will move towards the
field the rushing and because they are
moving they will drag the surrounding
fluids to move so what you have is
essentially actually because now it's
almost like you have a slip boundary
condition you do have that a very thin
layer
in this stained air and they set my
immobile ions that's very thin few
nanometers for example and this the rest
is all moving so it's like a plug flow
where the velocity distribution through
the whole channel is uniform right so
you draw it it's pretty much a plug flow
situation except they're really close to
the surface and so of course then you
have to balance your whiskers and this
is how people use the for example
electro osmotic pump right this is an
osmotic electro osmotic okay and you can
you can show that the velocity here of
this motion is epsilon 0 epsilon R and
they apply electric field and with casa
t and they are again the zeta potential
okay so that's the electro kinetics
including faradic
automatic and that due to the electrical
double layer and what we moving on next
is talking about surface tension and
phase change okay surface tension and so
what is the surface tension
first question is what's a unit of
surface tension hmm Newton per meter
okay so let's look at understand a
little bit more on surface tension and
surface tension is the energy so firstly
is the unit is Newton per meter right is
think of the typical as a force right
surface tension has a force but then I
can write this Newton times meter per
meter square
let's jar per meter square what is it's
a surface energy right so the surface
tension is how much energy I need to
create a surface okay and we can start
with the same material so if I have
material one right I want to break it
what's the minimum energy I need to
break this surface right the minimum
energy I leave is Weiss I break into two
halves
I gather exposed to a surface there
right so the surface energy is then the
surface energy gamma one is then they
work half of the work I need to do
minimum work I need to do to create this
two fresh surfaces right so that's the
cohesive energy it's the same material
how much energy noon you need it's a
cohesive energy right cohesion
and wo here is the work of cohesion and
so this is a one case now if i have two
different material one and the two how
much energy I need to break and create
the two different surfaces right mature
one and matures - okay and this is the
interface between two different
materials as my surface tension between
the two matures so from an energy
perspective it's much easier to
understand and my surface tension right
so surface tension exists - for any
surface
I'm not only liquid but also solid in
the surface tension in this case are 1 2
can be expressed in terms of the the
surface energy R 1 plus R 2 and minus 2
times R so here I only look at the one
worst part so one the worst part of this
break what how much wonder has surface
energy for if I break up surface one
only and the breaking up surface - okay
so this gives us some ways to estimate
the surface energy and surface tension
now you go back to the what we deal with
before right I can think about really
when I bring to surface together what
today here we discuss so what's the one
dwarfs force what's the one where's
potential between the two surfaces right
so with this basics that you can
actually do your
so the back of an envelope calculation
in terms of how strong is the boundary
between two surfaces and of course a
situ for this part there is a covalent
part right if you if you the two
surfaces a covalent bonded I just can't
deal with easily right I told you how to
calculate wanderers the dipole-dipole
interaction and charged dipole
interaction I can do easily the covalent
bond that requires more sophisticated
calculation based on for example condom
mechanics
Schrodinger equation solution okay so
with this basic I understanding you can
of course you all heard about the say
this na plus equation and so we have a
la plus equation if I have a sphere
simplest case is a sphere right and then
I have the difference in the local
radius of curvature I have the pressure
difference which you can see as you see
P inside outside and the is a two gamma
over R R is the radius of the sphere
right so that's the gamma is the surface
tension surface energy that's the NA
plus equation the young equation is when
you have a droplet on the different
surface where you have
whether they surface the droplet was
spread or not so the contact angle of
this is a really energy balance so you
can think of this it's much it's easier
in this case it will force balance
I have medium 3 medium 1 and medium 2
the contact angle theta so you do your
force balance you will say this is the R
- 3 gamma 2 3 and here gamma 1 3 and
gamma 1 2 so I have gamma 1 3 equals
gamma 2 3 cosine theta plus gamma 1 and
here this is the young equation so now
sometimes we call this an applause young
equation okay so this is you you know
this I'm sure and they have seen in
different situations and what I'm going
to discuss lecture is the size the
effect on phase transition okay and with
this basic understanding on the surface
tension let's look at the size effect on
phase transition right so if I have a
droplet or vapour bubble it turns out
that the thermodynamic properties of
this droplet of bubble are very
different from bulk materials and this
is based on if I have or this also apply
when I have a liquid say a solid
nanoparticle and the melting this could
all happen right so basically I'm
looking
I the Ukraine eager thermodynamics of a
party girl is the surrounding and this
part of our could be a liquid droplet or
vapor and when I look at the Ukrainian
right so what is the I'm looking at the
mass equal number what's the condition
for mastic when you grow right
what's condition
mass transfer huh you all forget so the
chemical potential gradient the current
potential on both side the equator right
you you the aquarium where you have
mechanical pressure heat is a
temperature mass is a chemical potential
can't forget that okay so with what I
have is the chemical potential equal
each other that's always my condition
and the chemical potential turns out in
the differential form for each phase
right this is that where you can see the
Gibbs free energy is the enthalpy minus
TS right and then for each phase the
Gibbs free energy is the MU times n
times mu number of particle times the
chemical potential and with this tool
together you can prove the Gibbs um you
have equation which says where I have s
DT - way the specific volume V P plus D
mu equals zero
okay that's a big starting point to
derive all the legs
expressions is a gibbs duhem relation
plus the pressure where because i want
to have the two phases this applied to
each phase when two phases are the
equilibrant demille difference between
the two at 0 because the mu prime mu
equals mu double prime so let's look at
the case where of course I have the
pressure difference D P prime minus P 1
double prime is T P prime equals to D 2
gamma over R right
that's the not plastic question and now
I consider first I consider the phase
change which happens also under constant
temperature right temperature doesn't
change between the in the phase change
process and at the equilibrium the two
chemical potential must be the same so
what I have here this doesn't change
this doesn't change and what I need to
have is then the two phases V DP y prime
PP prime equals V double prime D P
double prime right specific volume times
the pressure that's equal to each other
to balance to have the equilibrium
condition so that the chemical potential
on both sides and with this with the
tool I can replace say the pressure I
say one of this I can replace example
specific volume but I need to see which
one is we per face because I don't know
the real as I see in the vapor phase I
use the ideal gas law so if I have first
as a droplet I keep my P double prime
and so let me say if I have first I have
a droplet
if it's a droplet right and it's a
say-so we in the vapor phase I have a
prime equals RT and P prime right so in
the that's in the vapor phase up here we
prime equals so I can replace with P
Prime and then I can put a P double
Prime in terms of P Prime so I can
eliminate to have an equation to solve
for D P prime only and if you solve for
that so combined with the equation we
have you'll find out the P prime equals
p0 exponential and to gamma over R and
weight double prime R T V double prime
is the liquid the specific volume during
the of the liquid doesn't change right
doesn't change much so I keep that in at
the constant Y I do the integration and
this shows that if I have a droplet
liquid droplet right and small droplet
the corresponding outside vapor pressure
is higher right so what does that mean
if I have a cloud of droplets a
different size at the one temperature
what happens to the small droplet
the small broccoli will evaporate faster
because the vapor pressure is higher so
they would disappear so is the bigger
particle win right and if you do solid
for example that's called Oswald
ripening your nanoparticle together
bigger nanoparticle will eat the small
nanoparticles and if you do liquid let's
just say say the small vapor small
droplets disappear faster okay and now
if I do a bubble you do the same right
you reverse it right in this case so
your bubble is inside so P double prime
is say NRT and then you solve your
equation again what I have is P double
prime equals P 0 exponential minus 2
gamma our way prime outside there is a
liquid so V prime is constant RT so
pressure will be lower the vapor
pressure of the bubble is lower what
does that mean for example this is where
people want to use a capillary
condensation you have nano channels or
micron channels right the liquid that
will condense into the channel and in
the condensation let's suppose this is a
vapor we Prime and that say liquid is
here right now is half bubble right it's
the same scenario and in this case they
the oh I'm sorry this is a double prime
this is V Prime right that's the my
inside is double Prime this is the
inside the curvature here
is double prime right so what it says in
this curvature region the vapor pressure
is lower than bulk and what it means is
if I have a vapor here at a certain
temperature I can still have
condensation inside at that temperature
okay and that's a capillary condensation
and this will happen until you feel to
the top and you will surely at the top
of your curvature disappear you don't
have condensation anymore okay and you
can do further same same analysis you
can so here we're doing the C River
pressure analysis you can even do the
temperature analysis right so if I have
a nanoparticle and here I can write it
during the phase change process Delta s
is Delta H over T that's a phase change
temperature right so you can again go
back to the phase change process analyze
what would be the trend of my
temperature change of particles and
you'll find out if I have a small
particle the Delta H t0 musti equals
here is our log to gamma R plus P prime
over P Prime so what what happens is
that what this tells me if I have a
small droplet the melting temperature
compared to a flat surface melting
temperature will be lower okay and this
has been even proven in solid where
there experiment if you make a silver
nanoparticles
and you put the early temperature could
be as low as the melting temperature of
you let's say just one or two hundred
degree so people try to use this e
factor to print the nanoparticle make
printable circuit and you can put them
plastic and you'll fire up to a very low
temperature they will solidify the group
and in fact they say once I was thinking
about this I didn't fire pattern but
then somebody else did people say think
about this say using the interface right
and if you think about solder solder is
a lower temperature and let's say it's
typically made of alloys and alloy has a
lipid worst thermal conductivity but if
I just use a solar nanoparticle with low
temperature I can still fire the one
hundred two hundred degree and they will
group but big but it's permanent that's
once they grew big they have higher
thermal in here so that was C random I
used to have an entropy generation table
that's the one of the idea generator
given fire pattern somebody did a pear
pad so you can explore those kind of
different effects and this is our
classical all those relation would
derive by Kelvin okay it's Calvin wrote
over five hundred papers okay poor soul
new road twenty-seven papers position so
you don't have to write many papers who
knew your lane behind okay they're
people write a lot every paper is
important and the final comment is even
surface tension can depend on the size
okay so there are also theory on the
surface tension size dependent on
surface tension and this were discussed
in the book and with that I saw that
will close this discussion on liquid and
the last lecture what I'm going to do
I'm surprised that I can actually go to
a chapter ten many times I stopped
Chapter seven so you have the enduring
with me is very moving very fast but
I'll talk about more on the
linear response theory molecular
dynamics simulation